So, what do you make of that in and of itself?
Seven hundred percent in a year?
Elon Musk is now the richest person in the world as of today, passes Jeff Bezos.
Yeah, it's really incredible actually.
I mean, he's somebody I've known for a really long time.
I've looked up to him for a long time.
And here's what I would say that he built a great car company...
...and somewhere along the way, you know, about five or six years ago,...
...what I thought he was building was an energy company...
...and that eventually people would realize that climate change actually mattered.
And it's taken five or six years for everybody to realize the same thing...
...and he's being rewarded.
You know, the world's richest person should be somebody...
...that's fixing and fighting climate change.
I think the reality is that Tesla is a distributed energy business.
Right?
They are figuring out how to harness energy, how to store it...
...and then how to use it in a way to allow humans to be productive.
Cars are a manifestation, but you know, solar panels are as well.
Power walls are as well.
And I'm telling you right now, Scott,...
...the big disruption that's coming is to power utilities.